okay so we going to do ad me
now and I don't bring that tension into
me
okay let's
try so tips for this is uh your hand
starts
here okay don't start it up
here your is here elbow's going to go in
elbow goes
in okay then next tip is your body is
going to be in
a Kamaya structure so my hips aren't
Square th
sideways so doing those two things here
[Music]
so and this HP is going to turn the quad
you're going to turn the quad into it
okay you don't go
straight turns the clo into
the center
line turn the
CL elbow
in
the
okay so as an IO you're trying to
cultivate a skill to cultivate a skill
you need a stress a stressor then you
generate the adaptation the desired for
skill so you don't want to you're not
looking to reduce stress you're looking
to overcome stress it's not H waza so
I'm down here because look how much
mechanical advantage he has okay but I
want to learn how to just lift up my arm
lift up my arm lift up my arm lift up my
arm I don't want to start
doing these ways of taking off pressure
you understand so I'm not going to
go like that I bring BR my elbow in and
then lift my hand in space
Bo there is some
slight gaining or giving him some sort
of mechanical disadvantage cuz he's
angled here but I'm not trying to ignore
it Al together okay the reason that I
got that slight difference is just cuz
I'm going to bring my elbows in then
lift my sword
home
okay as you're better and
better it shouldn't be over here I
should lift my elbow turn my elbows in
and he's still pretty freaking strong
right there cool that's what I'm going
to try to lift
whoa not go oh he's still pretty strong
there let me come over
here
so if you pay attention to my Emi my
foot it's not going to go over this
way it goes right
[Music]
straight same thing goes on the throw
I feel his
Mass don't try to go around
[Music]
it I'm going to just go right through
it and when I go right through
it I'm not going to try to use my lats
and my
elbow I'm going to do the same same
relaxed movement I did when I brought my
hand up I make my hand
[Music]
heavy as my hand is loose at the end and
does fall all the way
[Music]
down relax
movement
relax
movement okay let's try
it all
right uh couple things to notice if I'm
doing that last part
correctly is he can't do his walk down
back
breakfall likewise towards that end my
hand will not drop outside my leg
okay so again I'll show that one my hand
does not drop outside my leg and he does
a sit down that's
Greatful because I'm trying to increase
the stressor I go right through his
Center not around his Center so in the
same way that I don't go around his
Center here I don't go around his Center
here I push through his Center
you notice he gets projected out he get
squeezed
out not falling over
there my hands either in front of my
knee with that foot or maybe slightly in
but my elbow's going to stay
on that Y Line
okay all right try it
again it's even here it's prevalent okay
uh you don't start in Comm then to go
end up in Comm you you start in Han me
in Han me my feet are underneath my hips
okay most people do Kam because that's
the only way they get the bracing angle
is he's he's pushing on me
but if I can ground one leg's enough
doesn't matter so H me is definitely
enough okay so don't start in Kam
because then your ademia is really small
so your displacement is small so the
exercise is shorter so the cultivation
in in regards to the adaptation is
smaller it would be like if doing bench
press and this is where you're operating
as opposed to touch the chest up touch
the chest up up okay so starting H Han
me so that you have a big entering and a
big
activation of the
glute last point we'll put it on film
when I was saying we did a video in
another ID tyo where I am giving ad me
and in the uh path of travel and the
timing for the travel I learn how to put
my
weight over the elbow there's a video
check it
out uh the same thing is going on here
okay yes I'm going through
him but he is being thrown down in other
words I'm not just projecting
out okay he is there is a downward
pressure so but it's the same thing so I
not only have the distance I get between
my legs but I have the distance as I
bring my front knee into the Yang line
which is uh in the vertical plane of the
front toes in that distance I'll
exaggerated for now elbow
in this is too late I'm below my hand
okay again if you have relaxed power
it'll work but it's not the exercise you
want a Time relax power with your Kam so
I have to figure out we go we're going
to kind of game it as I come
in coming
in here you can see that my weight is
now on top of that hand and the knee is
at its full y face then my hand can
drop so I'm not going to go here y face
that's going to be just hand with no
relaxed power you're going to want to
pull your elbow down okay
so time
it it's from straight angle to Young
line that's your
[Music]
timing
different that was more heavy hand and
the timy all right let's try
it you'll get your grips cool and you
come over you get your ribs okay so
there's all that pressure no I ground
the pressure I move it hold
in
no ground loose
arm you got to keep your
Gom
[Music]
okay let's try